ich möchte euch in diesem video gerne
auf eine tour durch meinen garten
mitnehmen und euch zeigen welche gemüse
man im winter immer noch anbauen kann
das nämlich viel mehr als man so denken
mag gerade wenn du garten zeitungen
liest dann hast du wahrscheinlich jetzt
öfters gehört dass du deinen garten im
oktober gefälligst zu räumen hast dass
du das ganze umgraben sollten den winter
über brachliegen lassen sollst davon bin
ich kein freund ich gerne ganz ohne
umgraben und ich achte immer darauf dass
der boden bewachsen ist
es ist nämlich nicht so dass man den
boden was gutes tut wenn man dem eine
winterpause könnte sondern im gegenteil
der boden möchte vielmehr immer
bewachsen sein das schützt den boden vor
dem grauen winterwetter das füttern die
bodenlebewesen die ja gerade in den
biogarten super wichtig sind ja wenn du
dich in der natur umschaut dann siehst
du einfach dass es nirgendwo nackigen
boden gibt also ist einfach was sehr
unnatürlich ist und was den bodenerosion
aussetzt und was ihn verarmen lässt und
deswegen verzichte ich darauf und bau im
winter immer noch ganz viel gemüse an so
was wie eine gartensaison gibt es
eigentlich bei uns gar nicht weil wir
das ganze jahr über sachen anbauen und
ernten das möchte ich euch heute mal
zeigen da das hier mein allererstes
youtube video ist will ich mich aber
erst mal vorstellen ich bin marie
vielleicht kennst du meinen blog
wurzelwerk punkt net in dieser youtube
kanal ist sozusagen die erweiterung der
ist glocks so da schreibe ich nämlich
über die themen selbstversorgung über
den gemüsegarten wir haben es gegen die
wir melden und machen käse und joghurt
wie halten hühner und versuchen
möglichst viel von dem was wir essen
selbst zu erzeugen
mittlerweile ist das auch mein job
geworden also ich gebe kurse zum thema
selbstversorgung genauer gesagt online
kurse
das ist der beste job auf dem feld und
ja jetzt wollen wir eben auch diesen
youtube kanal machen um euch noch besser
zeigen zu können wie das alles
funktioniert weil in schriftlichen
anleitungen finde ich es manchmal gar
nicht so einfach so detailliert zu
zeigen was man wann wie wo warum machen
muss und deswegen kommt jetzt hier der
youtube-kanal ich hoffe ihr werdet viel
spaß dran haben meine videos zu schauen
ich werde versuchen immer jeden sonntag
ein video zu posten
mal gucken wie sich das entwickelt ich
würde sagen sogar wenn du absolut
blutige anfänger bist kannst du es
innerhalb von zwei jahren schaffen dich
komplett während der warmen monate aus
im garten zu versorgen im winter ist das
aber schon schwieriger ich habe wirklich
ein paar jahre gebraucht bis ich das
ausgetüftelt hatte und das geheimnis
dahinter wie das funktioniert damit du
wirklich das ganze jahr über aus deinem
garten ernten kannst ist ein guter
anwalt im frühling da ist ja so die
pflanzzeit und die sehr zeit und dann
sehr in alle ihre gemüse aus aber die
ganzen gemüse die jagd auf den beeten
stehen sie wurden viel später gepflanzt
und gesät erst im juli august teilweise
auch erst im oktober
jetzt sehe ich auch noch ein paar postel
ein für den winter und da muss man dann
eben auch daran denken weil es eben
nicht nur diese serie pflanzzeit im
frühling gibt sondern für den
wintergarten hat man eben sozusagen noch
zum zweiten frühling im spätsommer
deswegen ist ein guter an bauplan super
wichtig weil ich dann auch das ganze so
packte dass die beete zu jedem zeitpunkt
optimal genutzt sind also ich plane von
vornherein okay wenn der frühlings
kohlrabi abgeerntet ist dann pflanzt ich
da wirsing pflanzen und den rosenkohl
und so weiter für den winter es ist
einfach super wichtig dass du dir da
vorher gedanken machst und dann weißt
wann du was pflanzen muss aber jetzt
wäre es zu spät um wirsing zu pflanzen
der muss jetzt ja schon groß sein weil
sobald es kalt wird wächst der nicht
großartig weiter dann kannst du zwar
immer noch beenden
aber der muss bevor es richtig kalt wird
diese größe erreichen die er jetzt hat
das ist mein küchengarten und ihr seht
das obwohl es jetzt fast dezember ist
alle beete immer noch gewachsen sind
oder so gut wie alle und die leer stehen
da kümmern wir uns gleich darum ich
fange mal hier vorn an und erzähle ich
was hier so wächst also
das hier ist das bild das ich dass ich
viele blumen gepflanzt und gesät habe da
haben wir ganz viele kräuter hier steht
noch ein vereinzelter chinakohl und rote
beete allem gemüse die ich euch hier
zeige sind relativ frosthart genau hier
haben sie herr winter zwiebeln dazu über
eine tolle sache weil man die im oktober
schon stecken kann und dann wachsen die
vor dem winter ihr seht ist so ein stück
weit wie frühlingszwiebeln und dann kann
man die entweder im frühling sehr früh
als frühlingszwiebeln essen oder auch im
winter oder man wartet ein bisschen und
dann sind die schon viel früher als die
normalen zwiebeln die man erst im
frühling steckt er
das ist der vorteil von denen und ich
habe die auch immer so weit auseinander
gesteckt dass ich dazwischen noch eine
reihe möhren sehen kann das sind dann
die allerersten hören im frühling weil
ich sehr auf mischkultur selbst und
möhren und zwiebeln sind ja so die
klassische mischkultur das funktioniert
wirklich sehr sehr gut dann haben wir
hier einen kleinen unfall
das ist feldsalat den hat mein sohn
gesät und dabei hat er es ein bisschen
zu gut gemeint lassen viel steht noch
viel zu dicht wenn er so dicht ist dann
kann da überhaupt nicht groß werden der
sollte jetzt eigentlich schon viel
größer sein und deswegen werde ich den
jetzt gleich vereinzeln ich nehme
einfach die überzähligen pflanzen
draußen setzt sie an die stellen wo es
noch nichts wächst in unserem garten
weil dann sind die auch gewachsen und
wir können nicht genug von feldsalat
bekommen und die kleinen pflänzchen muss
ich nicht wegschmeißen
[Musik]
so sieht du kannst du doch schon viel
besser aus und dann haben wir hier ein
paar hübsche herbst hin und daneben
schwarzen rettig das sind haben die ich
irgendwo in der tasche hatte ich wusste
überhaupt nicht was es ist herzlich mal
hierhin gesellt und jetzt so langsam
sieht man unterschiedliche rettig und
rüben
ja die sind auch allesamt relativ frost
hat hier haben wir ein beet mit dicken
bohnen
das ist auch wieder so eine sache ich
mach ja videos für meine kurse und ich
musste dringend im spätsommer ein
videofilm wie ich bete vorbereitet ich
hatte aber überhaupt nicht vor
zu dem zeitpunkt irgendwelche
kohlpflanzen sondern das was ich daraus
sehen wollte sind die gewohnten die ja
überhaupt nicht so viele nährstoffe
brauchen und wollen wieder cool und so
ist das total oft in meinem garten
manchmal lässt es sich einfach nicht
anders arrangieren ich bin gespannt wie
die bohnen damit umgehen es werden
definitiv kein stickstoff fixieren oder
nicht in dem maß wie sonst das mag man
ihm verzeihen aber ich hab ein bisschen
die sorge sie dann ziemlich drauf
stängeln und leicht umknicken und nicht
so kräftig werden weil es tut ihm
wirklich nicht so gut also nicht
nachmachen zu hause ich sehe meine
dicken boden am liebsten im spätsommer
weil das den vorteil hat dass die im
nächsten jahr also die überwintern mb
die sind frosthart dass sie dann nicht
so anfällig für die schwarze bodenlos
sind wenn ihr schon mal decke boden
angebaut habe dann werde ich
wahrscheinlich wissen dass die total ob
man den schwarzen bohnen läusen und ich
hab die beobachtung gemacht dass mit den
bohnen die im weg überwintern werden
dass die irgendwie resistenter sind dass
die bundes dass die bodenlose dann ist
so gerne daran gehen im nächsten bild
haben wie rote beete und möhren und die
decke ich sobald es kalt wird nächste
woche soll es schneien mit einem gärtner
schließt ab dass die vor kälte schützt
und dann kann man im winter immer noch
rote beete blätter essen oder auch die
kleinen knollen und die möhren werden
dann ja die sind jetzt noch nicht reif
über die wachsen auch weiter wenn man
die vor frost geschützt und so kann man
dann im winter auch möhren essen und die
sind so viel süßer als allem hören die
man im sommer ernten kann
sobald die einmal frost gekriegt haben
sind die göttliche jähnigen von euch die
meine kurse kennen werden sich
wahrscheinlich gerade wundern wo dann
über
hat man ganz mulmig ist von dem ich
immer so schwärmen ich bin nämlich ein
großer musikfan
ich habe allerdings in unserem
küchengarten dieses jahr in experiment
gemacht
könnte ich jetzt auch langsam mal
beenden aber ich wollte einfach mal
wissen was für ein unterschied macht
wenn man seine bitte nicht mich weil ich
ja ich habe quasi von anfang an meinem
gemüsegarten gewürdigt und ich war von
anfang an ziemlich großer fan davon aber
ich wollte eben auch mal den unterschied
kennen
den kenne ich jetzt durch die dicke
mulchschicht die ich normalerweise auf
meinen beten aus bringe muss ich quasi
nicht mehr gießen auch im so heißen und
trockenen sommern wie sie im moment
haben nicht und es wächst kaum unkraut
und das war schon ein enormer
unterschied den ich dieses jahr
festgestellt habe weil ohne gießen würde
er es hier überhaupt nichts wachsen also
normalerweise bin ich absoluter murks
ein und das bin ich auch nach diesem
experiment noch eigentlich bin ich das
nach dem experiment sogar noch um so
mehr
also ich freue mich auf nächstes jahr
wenn ich endlich wieder ruhig und habe
dann kommen hier meine beiden hochbeete
da wächst jetzt noch ganz viel rucola
wir haben hier mangold und wer weiß was
das ist kann mir das gerne mal in die
kommentare schreiben
das kennen nämlich nur sehr wenige leute
schmeckt ganz gut man kann es schon an
den blüten erkennen
ich nehme ich mit einer wildpflanze
verwandt die wahrscheinlich alle von
euch kennt ja
hier wächst ein bisschen vereinzelter
spinat hier ist noch mal mehr rucola
mehr mangold mangold ist auch
erstaunlich posthalter denker der gut
und gerne bis weihnachten bieten stehen
lassen oder auch länger je nachdem wie
kalt es wird dann ist hier eine fläche
wo ich jetzt postel einsehen will und
hier haben wir aber sehr salat und
dieses bild könnte interessant für alle
von euch sein die im winter immer noch
eigenen salat essen wollen dazu könnte
ich auch mein eigenes video machen
das ist eine salatsorten die relativ
frost hat ist die nennt sich backen kann
ich mal hier einblenden
leider kriegt man das saatgut nur sehr
sehr selten also ich bin froh dass ich
da vor drei jahren mal dran gekommen bin
an das saatgut und seitdem vermeer ich
den salat immer selber weiter weil ich
die so toll finde es ist eigentlich ein
kopfsalat aber ich baue den als
pflücksalat an im winter also ich sehe
den ganz dicht aus so dass da so ein
teppich entsteht er wird auch noch
weiter zu wachsen also es wird ein paar
wochen ganz dicht sein
wenn es kalt wird kriegt er einen fließt
über und so kann man den ganzen winter
über immer noch salat aus dem eigenen
garten essen und er ist ein paar super
lecker ich hab's ja eben schon erwähnt
ein guter an bauplan ist wirklich super
wichtig wenn man das ganze jahr über aus
dem eigenen garten essen möchte und
deswegen habe ich für euch einen anbau
plan erstellt der so ausgeklügelt ist
dass die beete wirklich das ganze jahr
über genutzt sind dann könnt ihr euch
gerne herunterladen kostenlos dass es
hier unter dem video verlinkt einfach
mal in der video beschreibung gucken da
könnt ihr euch dann für den plan
eintragen da kommen wir zu meinen kohl
bieten es gibt ja auch einige kollegen
die man im winter immer noch ernten kann
zum beispiel wirsing rosenkohl es auch
so ein klassischer tube rauch ist auf
rosstat und ich bepflanzte meine gebete
immer auch mit sellerie der ist auch
relativ frost hat also den kann man dann
immer noch ernten wenn du dein sellerie
einlagern willst dann solltest du ihn
allerdings vor dem frost erna hinter mir
geht es noch weiter mit ganz viel
rosenkohl rosenkohl ist so ziemlich das
beste wintergemüse finde ich ich liebe
den wir machen auch weiter groß
also davon haben wir immer jede menge
und diese stangen die ihr seht sind von
den kulturschätzen weil man ja cool
immer vor schädlingen schützen muss das
heißt alle grenzen bekommen bei uns ein
netz drüber das kann man jetzt wenn es
schon mal post gegeben hat abnehmen
aber die starken stehen hier immer noch
und die kann man sehr leicht auch so
elektroinstallations- hoch und selber
bauen ja da stecken wir metallstangen
links und rechts in die erde bieten die
mögen so zurecht und dann können wir da
das netz darüber machen hier ist noch
mehr rauch der ist leider platt
getrampelt worden mal von kindern einige
pflanzen kann man schon noch retten
andere sind schon irgendwie sehr
zermatscht genau dann haben wir auch
noch rotkohl auch relativ frost hat
daraus mache ich noch sauerkraut wenn
ich mal dazu kommen
hier ist wieder sellerie also das ist
einfach eine tolle mischkultur auch kohl
und sellerie zusammen der sellerie
beschützt und den kohl vor schädlingen
und trotzdem kommt ja noch das kultur
schutznetz drüber und lauch muss auch
immer abgedeckt werden weil der sonst
von der laut fliege malträtiert wird und
deswegen ist das eine tolle kombi da hat
man alle schützenswerten pflanzen gleich
unter einem netz er versteckt sich hier
noch ein kleiner kandidat ein bisschen
licht verschaffen das ist mein
gewächshaus das haben wir aber noch
nicht so lange also jetzt erst seit dem
spätsommer
da können wir auch mal reinschauen aber
das ist ziemlich chaotisch da drin also
die tomaten stehen noch drin
die kommen jetzt heute noch raus und
dann habe ich hier spiele hat gesellt
und winter zwiebeln wachsen hier ein
paar möhren dahinten radieschen und
mangold damir feldsalat noch mehr
zwiebeln noch mehr spinat der mangolds
nicht gut aus der es von tieren und
pilzen befallen und ich habe ehrlich
gesagt mich um dieses gewächshaus
wirklich schlecht gekümmert deswegen
sind die pflanzen auch alle noch so
winzig ich habe und man ist im september
so habe ich hier die ganzen winter
gemüse gesät und dann habe ich mich erst
mal zwei wochen nicht darum gekümmert
nicht gegossen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das noch
hinkriegen aber sonst werden wir im
frühling einfach blumenkohl und so
weiter hier ein pflanzen so dass wir
dann schon früh lernte im frühling haben
es ist sowieso eigentlich so dass die
zeit in der es wirklich schwierig ist
aus dem eigenen garten zu essen nicht
unbedingt der winter ist sondern
vielmehr der frühling und ich denke mal
dadurch dass ich jetzt das hier
irgendwie so verbockt habe mit den
aussaaten und mich da einfach nicht drum
gekümmert habe werde ich dann im
frühling umso mehr pflanzen und säen
damit wir dann wirklich auch schon in
der zeit wo die ganzen wintergemüse
aufgegessen sind leckere sachen aus dem
gewächshaus haben musst du dir das
einige gemüsepflanzen ihr eigenes
frostschutzmittel herstellen
das ist total fasziniert könnte das
pflanzen alles kennen das
frostschutzmittel das verhindert dass
sich eiskristalle im zellinneren bilden
weil wenn die zu entlassen
dann ist die pflanze dahin aber wenn es
nur in den zwischenräumen gefriert wenn
sich nur da eiskristalle bilden dann ist
das reversibel dann kann die pflanze
wieder aufbauen und wächst danach
einfach weiter als wäre nichts gewesen
ist total fasziniert ja das ist also
unser kirchengarten wir haben dazu noch
ein ak der ist noch mal ungefähr mehr
als doppelt so groß wird der
kirchengarten da wachsen alle gemüse die
jedem bisschen weniger aufmerksamkeit
brauchen wie kartoffeln und kürbis was
er mir dann auch gute biete das mit die
kartoffeln sind jetzt natürlich geerntet
und der kürbis auch aber nur damit ihr
wisst dass der garten jetzt für die
volle selbstversorgung noch nicht
ausreichen würde
zumindest nicht wenn man so viel gemüse
ist liege wenn ihr wollt kann ich auch
gerne meiner tour über den acker geben
im moment ist das ein bisschen trist
überhaupt wenn man im winter gärtner
dann ist es einfach nicht so romantisch
wie im frühling und im sommer aber alles
ist grau matschig es ist einfach nicht
mehr so schön aber was schönes ist wenn
man im winter immer noch ganz viel
leckeres gemüse aus dem eigenen garten
essen kann
deswegen lohnt sich das auf alle fälle
ich würde mich auf jeden fall sehr dafür
interessieren was in eurem garten wächst
schreit mir das gerne unten in die
kommentare
was sich jetzt nicht gezeigt habe ist es
mir gerade einfällt ist grünkohl der ist
natürlich auch sehr sehr post hat wir
haben auf dem acker welchen
auch nicht so viel weil wir nicht so die
grünkohl fans sind kohlrabi ist auch
relativ rosstat radieschen da gibt es
auf jeden fall noch einige andere
kandidaten aber ich würde mich sehr
freuen einfach mal zuhören was bei euch
wächst also lass mir gerne einen
kommentar da sah ich hoffe euch hat die
gartentour gefallen falls ja lasst mir
gerne einen daumen hoch da abonniert den
kanal ab jetzt gibt es nämlich hier jede
menge tolle videos drückt auch dicke
locker das muss man als youtuber ja
immer noch sagen
daran werde ich mich halten und vergesst
mich euch den garten plan runterzuladen
ich freue mich wahnsinnig auf diesem
kanal ich freue mich auf nächste woche
ich freue mich auf eure kommentare
macht's gut schießt